One of the most stunning revelations from
Bob Woodward's new book, Rage, is that Donald
Trump's former secretary of defense, Jim Mattis,
went to the director of National Intelligence,
Dan Coats, and said, Dan, the time may come
where we need collective action on Donald
Trump, which by every reasonable interpretation
that is code for the cabinet may have to come
together and use the 25th Amendment to remove
Donald Trump.
Bob Woodward's book also alleging that Jim
Mattis saw Donald Trump as, quote, dangerous
and, quote, unfit.
And in a separate conversation recounted by
Bob Woodward, Jim Mattis reportedly said to
the DNI, DNI Dan Coats, quote, The president
has no moral compass, to which Dan Coats replied,
True to him, a lie is not a lie.
It's just what he thinks.
He doesn't know the difference between the
truth and a lie.
So let's kind of dig into this at the big
picture level.
I'm guessing most of my audience understands
it's not normal.
It's not typical for multiple high ranking
individuals like the secretary of defense
and the director of national intelligence
to be talking together about, hey, we might
at some point need to act to remove the president
because he is unfit and he cannot lead.
That is not typical.
That did not happen.
During Barack Obama, it didn't happen during
George W. Bush, although certainly George
W. Bush did a lot of things that were absolutely
atrocious and disgusting.
This is not normal.
Now, what do they mean when they say collective
action?
By every stretch of of my imagination, it
can mean one thing and one thing only, which
is the potential use of the 25th Amendment
to remove a president.
Now, the 25th Amendment.
It's available.
This is a public document.
As you as you know, it has four articles in
it.
The first three refer to other circumstances
where a president would have to be replaced.
For example, if the president is incapacitated
for for some reason or if a president were
to die.
The fourth article of the 25th Amendment is
the relevant one here.
And thinking about what Jim Mattis was talking
about in that fourth article of the 25th Amendment
says that the vice president and cabinet officials
can vote on the removal of a president if
the majority votes for removal, meaning the
V.P.
Plus the cabinet, a letter goes to the leader,
the Senate pro temp and the speaker of the
House telling them we have voted to remove
the president.
The president is then able to respond if the
president disagrees with his removal or her
removal, in this case, his removal.
The president can write a letter to the Senate
in the House saying, I am fit to serve.
And then both houses of Congress would have
to vote now.
In the meantime, if the vice president sends
a letter saying, I agree that the president
is unfit until the House and Senate vote,
the vice president becomes acting president
of the United States.
It's sticky and it's sloppy and it's convoluted.
But the point here is Jim Mattis, the then
secretary of defense, brought this to the
director of national intelligence and said,
we may need to do this.
We may need collective action.
That alone is one of the biggest scandals
of the last many decades.
The fact that this was a conversation that
took place at the highest levels is completely
outrageous.
And out of this world, a scandal.
If the world made sense, Donald Trump would
have already resigned.
Based on everything that bill, actually, if
the world made sense, Donald Trump never would
have been elected, given that he was, if the
world made sense.
The countless scandals that Donald Trump has
been involved in would have led to a resignation
long ago.
The world does not make sense.
And instead, we are faced with the very real
prospect not of Donald Trump's removal, but
of Donald Trump being awarded another four
years.
And fascinating that there are Trump ists
who heard this news that Jim Mattis was thinking
we may actually have to remove this guy.
And some of those Trump has reacted by saying,
I told you the military was planning a coup
against Donald Trump.
Now, of course, Mattis is gone.
Mattis was talking about this in his role
as a member of the cabinet.
Happening to be secretary of defense.
This was not a military action that was being
considered a cabinet action.
But the fact that they will excuse anything,
they will find a way to say Donald Trump is
the victim here, Donald.
Billionaire guy born with a spoon in his mouth
has become in the eyes of many of his followers
and in his own eyes, the biggest victim, the
most poorly treated man on earth.
You would have he would have you believe it
is truly amazing.
And again, I don't want to get ahead of myself,
but I'm putting together my thoughts.
I don't think this is going to have any impact
on Donald Trump and we'll deal with that tomorrow.
In the meantime, what is your reaction to
these audio leaks?
Do you think they will have any bearing whatsoever
on the upcoming election?
Let me know on Twitter where you can find
me at Deas, Pacman
D. PJAK, MRN, The David Pakman Show David
Pakman
dot com.